think you know a lot about the Big Apple
here's 18 facts about New York even New
Yorkers don't know one in every 38
people in the u.s. lives in New York
City 800 different languages are spoken
there making it the most linguistically
diverse city in the world pinball was
banned in the city until 1976 it's a
misdemeanor to fart in New York City
churches it's completely legal for women
to be topless in public in New York up
until World War two everyone in the city
who was moving apartments had to do so
on May 1st November 26 2012 was the only
day in recent history with no report of
violent crime in the city 57% of all
cigarettes sold in New York City are
black market smokes smuggled in
illegally philadelphia cream cheese was
actually created in New York the name
was changed to Philadelphia because it
was better known for cheese at the time
Albert Einstein's eyeballs are stored in
a safe deposit box somewhere in the city
go find them commercial delivery
companies receive up to seven thousand
parking tickets every day in Manhattan
the Empire State Building has its own
zip code there's an abandoned train
platform under the Waldorf Astoria Hotel
it's totally creepy and cool Madison
Square Park Washington Square Park Union
Square Park and Bryant Park all used to
be cemeteries there are 20,000 bodies
buried in Washington Square Park alone
due to a clerical error Madison Square
Garden has not paid property taxes since
1982 in 1981 a nine-year-old boy robbed
a New York bank and got away with 118
dollars and finally three quarters of
the crosswalk buttons in New York City
are placebo they haven't worked since
the 80s what's your favorite fact about
New York